[Musique]
les violons du roy c'est une quinzaine
de musiciens permanents et une bonne
dizaine d'autres contractuels les
cachets qui sont perdus avec
l'annulation de ce spectacle printanier
frôle le demi million de dollars et la
catastrophe annoncée pourrait bien
s'alourdir avec annulation possible
d'une série de concerts estivaux au
québec et en europe
c'était la période la plus chargée de
l'année de la mi mars à la fin juin on
avait 36 concerne la v10 concerts aux
états unis quand six concerts c'est
quand même considérer un petit 40% de
des concerts de la saison
la grande question c'est savoir à quel
moment on reprend tout ça
l' orchestre espère être admissible au
programme fédéral l'aide aux pme mais
attend toujours la confirmation on
arrive le projet roma d'albums qui est
visé donc on avait des mois qui est
préchargé présentement mars avril mai ça
comptait pour au-dessus de 70% notre
année donc c'est sûr que c'est à lui un
moment effectivement les membres du
quatuor quark se font appel à l'aide
d'urgence fédérale pour les travailleurs
autonomes ils ont perdu 57 spectacle
le groupe est constitué en organisme à
but non lucratif et le gouvernement n'a
rien prévu pour eux mais il faut se
rappeler qu'en mai 68 milles au bn alpes
pour bnl présentement québec en attente
de mesures pour nous aider on aimerait
savoir à peu près les mêmes ressources
que les pme la scène culturelle de la
grande région de montréal génère près de
10 milliards de dollars par année et
plus de cent mille emplois
en temps normal partout les salles se
posent les questions à savoir qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec la notion même de ce que
nous représentons c'est à dire le
plaisir du rassemblement on est on
exactement les verse puisqu'on nous on y
sent de chez toi sans doute à zone de
confort on est les verserait spa maison
la discipline la russe
le monde du théâtre est aussi
complètement bouleversé les troupes
perdent leur contrat et les sorties
scolaires sont annulés
et comble de malheur ils ne peuvent pas
organiser des répétitions n'ont plus
distanciation physique oblige on voyage
et on se tait on va se relever de son
envol à l'art vivant
continuer d'exister
et
l'ampleur des pertes ont peut-être
entamé même capacité à maintenir les
activités telles qu'on les avait prévu
l'année prochaine
les artistes sont pour la grande
majorité des travailleurs au statut
précaire
la crise actuelle pourrait bien
entraîner la disparition des compagnies
les plus fragiles à moins que les
autorités ne désigne la culture comme un
service essentiel
ce pas un bien qui est qui est essentiel
au niveau physiologique l'alcool mais ça
m'aide à passer au travers et je pense
que la présente l'entente va faire
exactement la même chose
[Musique]
l'ol
ça
non
un chrono
ah on n'est pas des médecins on n'est
pas sur les bons mais je pense quand
même qu'en bout de ligne
l'art est complètement essentiel surtout
dans des moments de crise comme ça
[Musique]
joyau